foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting for
the PODS of moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five and I
am at Rachel Cruz hosting at this hour
with best-selling author and the Ramsay
personality Ken Coleman so we are taking
your calls about anything life money
relationships career so give us a call
and if you like the show if you guys
enjoy the Ramsay show whether it's on
YouTube or podcast or traditional radio
make sure that you know tell your
friends about it share the news uh talk
about you know kind of even what you
find interesting and introduce your
friends to it because our goal it's why
we sit in these chairs for three hours
every single day and do a live show is
to help America we want to really hit
against the toxic culture that's going
on and hopefully give some hope and some
direction for what's going on in your
life so again give us a call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right up first of the show this hour
Catherine in la oh love Los Angeles hi
Catherine welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me I I think I need
some tough love as I sit in my Tesla
um
the tough love because Rachel loves her
a Tesla I do love a Tesla yeah mine's
paid for all day very nice perfect so we
have to sell it we're doing good
so I do
I think I have so many complicated
questions until I play over what I think
you guys are going to say to me and and
I know the answer so I was debt free a
millionaire with a property that was you
know had a lot of equity and you know
some money in the bank and a good income
and I was a single mom I was widowed at
39. oh wow and
I I had a nice Nest Egg no debt I met a
fantastic man
um we got married a few years ago and
with this awesome guy that you know
adopted my daughter came a massive
amount of debt
um to the tune of close to a half a
million dollars and it was school loans
and some credit card and some high
interest uh short-term debt and I want
to know
um you know the nest egg that I had
built up was mine but it's ours
um the home equity we sold that house
bought a house that we could all live in
we still have a lot of equity in that
house
but am I paying off his school loan so
that we can be debt free we have two
paid for cars we have a lovely income I
just really have a hard time paying off
his past life yeah and I hear that and
and I
um you know I feel like it's easier for
us to kind of harp on the ones that just
got married and they're like oh it's his
debt my debt like you've just sent her
to a marriage you know but when you've
lived two separate lives in a sense
right um because you got married later
had kids and it's like you're merging
these two lives I think it's a it's a
harder uh pill to swallow so I hear that
Catherine so don't say that this is I'm
not saying that it's just easy because I
do have my answer and it is kind of
black and white but I want you to hear
that
um it is hard like I I get that I
absolutely get that uh but here's here's
the benefit let me say that when couples
can come together in a sense that you
say okay this money that was mine now
I've been entered into a marriage and
that means I am becoming one with
someone else and in every area of my
life and there's a sacrifice to that
right you could put in money you could
put in time with that you can put in
maybe the way you want to raise kids how
you want to spend holidays I mean you
could insert anything into that and we
just find that couples that have a
sacrificial spirit in a sense to say hey
I'm laying everything down and together
we're going to build a life as one they
Thrive and not just financially because
financially I believe they do because
you can run a race so much faster when
both of you are on that same page but I
think it's even deeper than that
Catherine there's a there's a there's a
spiritual element there that when you
say everything that I have is yours even
this nest egg and as hard as hard as it
is to be like oh
when you become one with that person it
does something in your marriage there's
an intimacy and a richness there now
I'll I'll let Kim jump in a second but
my own my other asterisk though
Catherine is I really want to make sure
that he's done with this right if his
spirit is and his attitude is God was so
stupid I took out all those loans I wish
I didn't uh never doing it again we're
living debt free and it's this attitude
shift as well that you guys have the
same value system then I feel like it
would be easier to say yeah we're in
this together now
if he doesn't and he's still kind of
messing around with debt and it's a
value system of yours to live debt-free
then we have a marriage issue there of a
values issue does that make sense
Catherine
absolutely and and I I so connect with
what you said I think where I've played
this is you know I put our house on a
15-year mortgage we paid off both of our
cars and I have him putting all of his
income into his school loan payments
every month and I hit the house really
hard and I make sure everything else is
debt free I don't know that if I just
paid those off if that money that he has
every month that's going off those loans
would just disappear so I I don't know
that okay so I feel like we're on the
same page when we talk retirement but I
don't know of short term he would have
the intensity to get that loan debt off
and that money might just disappear
somewhere else okay that that's what I
was wondering because I could feel that
you were like I know what you're gonna
say and I know that there's something
that's really eating at you are you guys
I have two questions are you guys uh uh
shared you guys shared bank accounts you
guys doing all your money together you
guys separate bank accounts
um separate bank account yeah I I can I
could tell I pay all the bills I know so
it's but here's my point here's why I
asked the question that's what's eating
at you because you've got some natural
psychological tension and that's why
Dave and as an extension we for decades
have said we want you and Rachel just
gave you the whole Unity thing and so
you agreed with everything Rachel said
so if you agree with everything Rachel
said I know you did
so you guys need to combine bank
accounts because that's where the
tension is coming from you're like this
is my money oh yeah I've worked hard and
then you're like I'm having him put all
of his income into the student loan and
so therein lies the tension by which you
called today so I I listen first of all
let me say
I completely understand why you feel the
way you feel I share Rachel's opinion on
I get it but you guys have decided to be
married and it's a long-term play yes or
no
yes yes so today
we combine bank accounts I still like
the strategy of taking all of his income
I love the intensity but I would not do
him on the student loans and you own the
house it's no we're going to put this in
the baby steps so we're gonna put the
student loans in baby step two and
you've done this before and so both of
you attack the student loans and then
both of you pay off the house yeah and
Catherine hold on because Austin's gonna
pick up and we're going to give you a
year subscription to Ramsay plus and it
has every dollar in there which is our
budgeting app and I was just texting
with my husband this morning about a
horse because I was like what's this
venmo where should it Go and so I want
you guys to budget together for three
months okay and I want to say by
February there might be a more emotional
ease for you to pay everything pay it
all off together as a team once you guys
have been even from a tactical sense
budgeting together it's coming out of
one account like there is a Unity there
versus a separation like Ken was saying
so Catherine I hope that helps but stay
on the line Austin will pick up this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
was made for you the never quitting
non-stopping gazelle intents
with gazelle you can say goodbye to
monthly fees and experience a seamless
integration with every dollar so no
matter how or where you spend you are
always in control and since gazelle is
FDIC insured you don't have to worry if
your money is safe
gazelle the debit card that helps you
spend and save the Ramsay way
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show so there
was a
I don't know funny funny is that the
word a funny commercial an ad that came
out exactly one year ago today
and it has not aged well Ken no you're
talking about uh uh Matt Damon Matt
Damon it was only funny in that it was
so cheesy serious you know I remember it
was like these big bold historians do we
have it I think we have it we have the
actual commercial oh let's roll this
play it
with those who almost adventured who
almost achieved But ultimately for them
it proved to be too much oh devastating
then there are others the ones who
embrace the moment climb up snowy
mountain look at this guy and commit yes
and in these moments of Truth these men
and women the airplane the Wright
brothers
mere mortals didn't get that one well
like they're just in the club as they
peer over the edge
they calm their minds and steal their
nerves
four simple words that have been
whispered by the Intrepid since the time
of the Romans wait for it fortune favors
the brave
crypto.com yeah so okay so I remember
watching that that was perfect that's
like I thought it was a Velveeta
commercial like we were going to see so
a block of cheese it like float through
the sky so bad and uh and so this is fun
because this was a year ago and you want
you know there's a term now that kids
use on social media what is it like this
tweet didn't age well oh yeah yeah
you've heard that phrase well this
commercial did not age well let's just
look at the numbers
uh by the way I like Matt Damon okay
none of this is an attack on Matt Damon
you know the guy got paid handsomely to
say all those ridiculously cheesy lines
uh had you uh uh calmed your mind
and did what Matt Damon told you to do
and you spent a thousand dollars uh
worth on bitcoin that day
um it was worth 60 608 back then near
its peak price which is pretty amazing
it would now just be worth three hundred
and forty dollars oh boy oh so I don't
know if fortune favors the brave or the
wise I think it's the wise now am I sane
I mean Dave and I have talked about this
you know just just kind of privately
about cryptocurrency I mean right now it
is so wildly speculative not just
because of the ups and downs but because
these kind of things rarely go
unregulated that's the whole point it's
going to be unregulated government well
guess what now the body Administration
has already come out and say well we're
going to come out with ours other world
government's gonna do the same thing and
and so when something is unregulated
it's also unprotected and you can lose
your shirt at a whole lot of other
things so pretty interesting and and and
we have some fun at this because this is
why we preach wisdom
with money don't be speculative and take
this because Matt Damon could talk you
into going oh wow I want to be like
Orville uh Orville and Wilbur oh right
and I want to fly a plane and I want to
invest my brother's first names somebody
has to well done well it's you got to
make fun of me sometime during the show
today but I mean it's it's just it's
playing on our emotions right now to get
us to do something and then walk around
going hey
I'm Really Brave and what you really are
is your adult you're a [ __ ] if you make
a decision Financial like that with no
background no research and it's a wild
risk might as well just take a thousand
dollars and burn it well for me it's the
long-term track record that's what I
always go back to right if I'm gonna put
my money in something I'm like I just
want to know that there's like it's not
everything's being predictable right the
market you know who knows what's gonna
happen after November the midterms and
then the market when you see something
move like like you don't know we don't
have a crystal ball but you can look
over the scope of time on something and
for me if it's my hard-earned money that
I've worked for
like I just want to I want to put it
somewhere that I know right and have
pretty great certainty that over the
course of time right uh I'm gonna make
more on it so uh yeah the crypto thing
and it's so it's such a fascinating
thing because I just feel like so many
celebrities have jumped on it well of
course they jumped on they get paid
handsome money to do yeah I know but he
doesn't even know what cryptocurrency is
it's not like there's like an online
bank that all these you know that's like
it's just it's pretty funny just the
just that whole genre and they've
attracted the celebrity pop culture
aspect well our colleague George
Campbell likes to call crypto what does
he call Mary Kay for young men it's a
great line and I will say this really
quick before we move on the thing I love
about that commercial that is so
ridiculously funny is it's all about
these big bold moves and it shows a dude
making his move in a nightclub like what
was that doing in there I still don't
get this like here's here's a guy
climbing Mount Everest here's space
astronauts and then here's some dude hey
I just don't get it so anyway well one
year ago today that Matt Damon
challenged you the fortune Brave favors
the brave you wouldn't better off taking
that thousand dollars and playing craps
with it in Vegas specially with me as
you're at your table you are the
hottestine you have the hot hand no
question at all all right up next is Psy
in Utah hi Psy welcome to the show
Hi how are you doing well how can we
help
well I just have kind of a two-part
question
um trying to just plan for the future
um I'm 21 and my girlfriend is 21 as
well
um we're just trying to decide you know
how we should go forward with looking
for a place to live we want to get
married sometime next maybe late spring
early summer and with the way house
prices are right now and we just weren't
sure if we should rent or look into a
small cheaper home but
my I I was gone for the past two years
serving a mission for my church and so I
wasn't making any income during that
time I've been home since May and I've
been working uh started a trade school
and my girlfriend has been saving like a
mad woman for those two years as well
um she's managed to save about eighty
three thousand dollars oh wow um good
for her yeah yeah she did she did
awesome there that's great well well let
me tell you this Psy one of the things
that we have found
um is in that first year of marriage I
would just rent I wouldn't put the
pressure of finding a home
um because you'll soon find out very
quickly that a home ownership in general
is just very expensive and there's just
a level of responsibility that you take
on as a homeowner and if you don't have
to have that especially your first year
marriage of transitioning and kind of
figuring out life together and you're
able to just rinse and you have a
landlord you let the housing market do
what it's going to do but you guys then
have a chance to say okay what part of
the city do we want to live in you know
where specifically do you want to be how
far do we want to be from our parents
how close do we want to be from our
parents like well that's a key detail
all of that you just learn a lot about
life and each other and even what you
want like as you as you live life
together even over a year you start to
see okay here are the things that we
really value that we are going to want
in a home and you just don't know all of
that before you're married so I always
recommend pausing that first year of
marriage so you're looking at again
spring summer of 24 to buy something and
you guys have time don't rush it you're
okay
um everyone's gonna be like buy a house
by house buy a house by house renters go
to hell buy a house buy a house buy a
house and it's like you don't have it's
okay it's okay you're not throwing money
away you're being patient and you're
being wise so that that's what we always
recommend
so the other part of my question then is
a lot of people in my family have been
kind of pressuring me to maybe get a
credit card now and start building
credit so that I can help her to maybe
take out a loan eventually and I don't
know if that's the smart thing to do or
not because I'm after listening to this
show I'm pretty terrified to yeah
totally well the reason that you build
up a credit score yes is some people say
well to get a mortgage and that is true
you use a credit score to get a mortgage
but you also don't have to have a credit
score to get a mortgage you can do
what's called manual underwriting but
you guys are going to be current on a
job and with other bills for I think on
average two years so the process does
take a little bit longer but it's worth
it it's not worth going in and playing
the credit card game and trying to get
your points and get your credit score up
and do all of that it's worth just
staying debt free you guys having that
black and white value system I think is
really helpful to stay together we're
not taking on any debt but hold on the
line Austin's going to pick up we're
going to give you Financial Peace
University for you guys as a wedding
gift for it to come and you guys go
through it together and then you guys
make these decisions together uh but
hopefully you come come to the same page
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
on Wednesday we announced our very first
smart conference weekends a full weekend
here in Nashville and it'll actually be
our very first event at the new Ramsay
Event Center this is very exciting so
fun oh we cannot wait to host you guys
and Nashville I mean it's a destination
city come on and hot chicken waffles
Chicken and Waffles country music I mean
you never know who you're going to run
into I know it's so good and smart
conference it's it's probably one of my
favorite events that we do it is the
biggest event that we do at Ramsay and
it is a jam-packed event that we cover
every area of your life so again we're
hosting it at the new Ram Event Center
and it's going to be the entire weekend
and it's not only again going to to help
you in your in your life in every area
of your life but we're going to make it
a full Nashville experience so and we
got a Friday night then all day Saturday
which is so so the stuff that we're
scheming and dreaming about for that
Friday night you just never know who's
going to show up I know it's so great
you know what I mean you never know here
in Nashville we've got some good friends
in Nashville we do or no you never know
we do but the personalities will be
speaking
um all day Saturday and maybe even
Friday we'll see but it'll be myself
Dave Ramsey Ken Coleman sitting here
next to me George Campbell Dr John
zaloni and Christina Ellis and here's
the deal we only have limited tickets
for this event and the Platinum level is
already sold out is it really two days
already sold out people want to come to
Nashville yes so there's things that
obviously these are going fast but we
still have only VIP and general
admission left wow and every pass will
include a souvenir badge to commemorate
the grand opening weekend which is so
great the Ramsey Event Center is a
shining City on a Hill literally it's a
monster edifice that is uh just
beautiful it's awesome it is awesome so
that weekend is April 14th and 15th
again it's a Friday and Saturday Friday
night and all day Saturday in Nashville
are you kidding me wonderful tickets
start at 79 and you don't want to wait
so go to ramseysolutions.com events to
reserve your smart your spots at smart
conference I can't wait for that can I
wear linen that early or do I have to
wait till Memorial Day do you know what
the cutoff is
not many minutes not many men in my life
ask about linen is it jacket or pants I
don't know I started thinking about a
spring event getting all fancy for the
people and I thought is it too early for
linen no April no April feels right I
feel good I typically wear the linen for
Easter Sunday I like to break out the
linen seersuckers were you as you're
sucker Stacy really likes preppy Ken wow
she does yeah wow and I do too let's be
honest you know man that like takes me
back to college we did Seer sucker in
college you know back in the day but
yeah there's nothing wrong with it and
uh to really to really just you can yeah
and I like to wear the saddle shoes with
them so that just really brings the
whole outfit whole outfit so that's true
if you come to Smart conference despite
Dave's objections I will wear some
seersucker pants with uh with some
saddle shoes I think fantastic and it's
worth every penny with every penny you
pay for it yep there you go all right
next up we have drew Ann in Lancaster
Pennsylvania hey Drew welcome to the
show
absolutely how can we help
in the past five months I um I recently
bought a house so I'm new to having a
mortgage and I might have bought a car
too so I have a car payment and I just
wanted to know what you guys recommend
me doing as far as paying them both off
like do it I'm guessing you're gonna say
do the car first but
I just wanted to see what you guys think
like what I should do sure
um how much do you make a year Drew
um I make around five grand a month okay
and how much is the car payment
uh 600 okay
um how what other debt do you have
that's a just a house and car just that
okay how much is the car worth
um
I'm I think in today's market like 40
Grand
okay
Drew
I'm gonna tell you to sell the car
okay that's that's what I thought
as much as you take home if you if you
you know what I mean like I mean it's
almost what you make in a year yeah I
know true how old are you
21. yeah it's great you're fine listen
we all made mistakes we all make
mistakes what kind of car is it it's a
Subaru WRX oh yeah okay gotta get rid of
it 2021 I know come on Drew because
here's the deal no one should ever pay
that much 600 car payment a month
can you imagine if you just kept it if
you just had that money
so do you guys recommend I just take
what I have saved and buy like a well a
beater car or yeah yeah man you got to
save up for something a little nicer
it'll motivate you to get something
better than the beater
okay uh how much do you have in savings
uh around 15 grand okay good for you
good for you so wait wait wait wait so
hold on what's the car worth you think
car is worth what I owe I just bought it
when I bought the house like six months
ago all right so basically zero out a
little bit so you would have so you
would have uh do you have any other debt
no okay so you got a thousand dollars in
the emergency fund yes
yeah so you got 14 to work with yeah
dude let me just tell you something I
I'm very passionate about this subject
because I'm looking for a car for my 16
year old yes so I'm looking all the time
all right dude listen to me you can get
way better than a beater for 14 Grand
right now you absolutely can't okay yeah
so I I love your spirit but you don't
have to get a piece of crap not with
what you've got and Drew I would even I
would even back it down not I wouldn't
spend all 14 Grand I would yeah keep
some in savings because you want to have
a three to six month emergency fund so
you'll get that pretty quickly
um and once you have that complete then
you can look to see so I would buy
something now seven to ten yeah seven to
ten keep the keep the remainder you know
build up your emergency fund whatever
that is
and then from there you're like okay you
can save then save up and and and you
can keep stepping up in car that's the
great thing about obviously the Market's
a little strange right now but that's
the great thing about cars is I'm like
you can continue to like you can drive
something you can kind of make it look
all nice sell it right now maybe sell it
for more than what you bought it for
possibly I gotta look into it and then
keep just stepping up so you a car is
not something that you feel you have to
have you know like a house we want you
to have it more than five years but a
car you can keep stepping up whenever
you want so that's the thing and I just
don't want this 600 I want you to start
investing into retirement I want you to
start doing things for the long term and
paying off the house early and this 600
is going to go so far for you true so
far for you so
um I would just chalk it up to saying
hey uh do it today I made a I made a
mistake I got In the Heat of the Moment
buying a new house my new car I want to
be an adult I'm 21 I'm out on my own
and you got a little a little ahead of
yourself true so I would uh I'd sell I'd
sell the car and do it now like don't
wait for this to wear off and somebody
else to talk you out of it yes you know
that's what I worry about young people
we got so many people that are older
than them that have a place of influence
in their life and and they tell them to
do stupid stuff you know we had a we
just have a video I wonder if we still
have it uh uh it was an old video back
when I started speaking right out of
college this was 13 years ago I used it
in my presentations for high schoolers
it was called dry free retire Rich yeah
and Alan Harris used to be on the
content team here he voiced it yeah and
it was this great four minute video yeah
and it showed instead of having a car
payment if you invested your money and
you invested a car payment every month
yeah and then on the side you saved up
some money and you kept stepping up in
car basically what you could make in
just interest on that mutual fund by the
time you're like 55 would pay for new
cars for the rest of your life taking
that interesting so it's just the power
of where are you putting your money and
when you're putting your money in a car
payment in an alone and paying interest
on something that's going down in value
for the most part no used cars are weird
right now but do you mean it's just this
mindset shift of how do I use my money
to work for me yeah instead of letting
it work for the bank and that's what
ends up happening when you take out a
car payment that's absolutely right yeah
I love it I just think so many people
get I mean there's there's a very
popular subset or set of videos out on
Tick Tock of people just telling
everybody with a giant smile on their
face how much they owe and what their
car payment is like it's a badge of
honor and people are like we owe 1200
and they're like all excited about it
and it's just become the norm to where
it's just like hey everybody does it so
we don't even think about how
detrimental it is to our financial life
and our life in general so what it could
be yeah these cars are great paid for
cars are even better yes thanks Drew for
calling hope you make the right decision
sell the Subaru this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting it this hour with
Ramsay personality and best-selling
author Ken Coleman by the way I I should
have emailed you before the show or
maybe a courtesy text to tell you to
wear your uh UT stuff because I know
you're very proud uh we were at a live
event and you were telling everybody
that would listen you know go Vols which
you should go false and I'm wearing the
Michigan gear today the Michigan
Wolverines undefeated so both of our
teams are in the top four uh I believe
uh and so which I still it still just
makes my heart glad when I hear that I
haven't heard that phrase I know for the
University of Tennessee welcome welcome
the water's nice
and over probably we're winning this
program by the way in college football
history Michigan is total wins so I just
want to point that out and we play
Sparty our heated right and I think that
you're because Kneeland stadium neylands
is slightly less seats than Michigan a
big house I know but we're the two
largest two largest stadiums I know and
Tennessee's what 106. somewhere in that
range I should have but the point is is
I should have had you wear some
Tennessee gear I didn't let you know
that I actually had my old uh sweatshirt
on this morning
yeah lady out in the lobby right now uh
at Ramsey Solutions watching She's she's
touting her Wisconsin gear I don't know
why God bless her so sorry they're
terrible sorry but uh we still like her
oh fall is great A little bit of
trolling and trash talk it starts the
second chance oh we love football we
love football especially college
football yeah it's fun it's the best all
right up next we got Tracy in Nashville
hey Tracy welcome to the show
hey how are you guys today we're doing
great how can we help
so my husband and I are going to be
receiving some money at the end of this
year and we're not sure what to do with
it
how much you're calling for suggestions
okay
um between what we're going to be
receiving and what we have in the bank
we're going to have about 700 000. whoa
that's great how much is that I'm
curious how much have you guys saved how
much of that 700 000 is what you saved
versus what you're going to receive
uh we saved 130 of that okay so it's a
lot coming from the cell of this that's
great give us uh give Rachel a snapshot
here so do you have any debt
we are debt free house too we make yes
everything is paid off completely
amazing um our income is between 350 and
400 a year whoa for you guys traces this
is all this is all new this is all just
kind of transpired within the last few
months so okay we're not sure what to do
with this one up coming in and then
we're not sure what to do with all the
extra that we're not going to have on a
monthly basis okay so
um so what happened in the next the past
few months that created this big this
big of a change
um a firm that we were a partner in was
merged with another company so we
received
um our investment return okay I gotcha I
gotcha and will you still be making that
kind of money after this all happens
yes you will okay that's great well well
done Tracy that is very exciting
um so you know when it comes to this
kind of thing and and there's no debt
you have obviously savings you know it
gets down to those Basics Tracy that
what you do with money you can give it
you can save it and you can spend it and
I recommend doing all three so I would
sit down with your husband and
um and I would look at and say okay what
are what are things that we are
passionate about so that we want to give
to and I would really plug in to you
know as many as you guys want but maybe
two two places uh whether they're
Ministries or whether they're
non-profits but something that that you
guys really have a heart for and I would
encourage you to dig into all of that
and and give some of this the amount you
know up to you what you want you know we
always teach giving 10 uh and even more
uh but I would recommend that I would
put some in Investments I would continue
to fund retirements and then you guys
can look to see okay you know what else
we want to do do we want to open up a
mutual fund throw some money in do we
want to do real estate because with this
kind of money you could buy buy a
property if you've wanted to and kind of
get into into real estate as an
Investments and then you guys need to
take some of this and enjoy it and go on
a nice trip or buy something that you
wanted to buy for a while you know uh I
would I would recommend to enjoy some of
it as well so it's really those three
buckets
um which is what's so funny about money
to me Tracy is like those are the three
things I teach my kids as you give you
save you spend and it's just the truth
of what we can what we still do today
and and I would recommend yeah doing
doing all three uh Tracy I would look up
several smart Vester pros at
ramseysolutions.com right here in our
area and I would sit with a minimum of
three if you don't already have one do
you have one already
we do and we they aren't aware of this
money yet we just found out this week
okay great great okay so let me Plan
before we tell them great because what
we have in the markets down 30 so I'm
not sure I want to put it in the market
yeah but that you know that it's a
discount right now and especially for
you guys where you at you are
financially in unbelievable shape I
haven't stopped investing in my 401k I
haven't stopped investing because I'm
getting stuff at a discount and just
give you an idea I don't know what it's
done the last day but two or three days
this week the market was back up so you
know this is the roller coaster it's how
it goes uh just I'll revise my advice I
want you to go sit with your smart
investor Pro you guys already have a
relationship and go hey here's what's
happened and I think Rachel's advice is
tremendous I think I would give I first
of all I'd celebrate I'd spend some do
something great with that kind of
windfall make a memory for crying out
loud that's what Stacy and I would do
we'd go okay we're gonna carve out I'm
serious carve out some of this money and
do something that you'll talk about when
you're 80. I do that I think Rachel's
right I would I would I would give a
nice chunk covet out of gratitude and
making an impact and then the rest of it
I would invest with your smart investor
Pro and multiply that windfall for more
celebrating more giving so I think
you're in great shape sit down and come
up with a plan and they'll walk you
through all your fears by the way tell
them that
you you got to sit with your smartest
program you know what
accounts can take a 30 percent d na I
want to sit on this and let's just walk
through it talk through all the
scenarios but I think you guys are in
great shape but I'm glad you have a
smart investor Pro you can trust and
this is amazing
but hey great can I just tell you I want
you to have a Little Dream session
tonight
like like what's that big memory that we
might make you know let's go celebrate
with some of this it's kind of just been
shocked about it all so I think for sure
in a little while that's right that's
right so helping you come out of the
shock let's dream a little bit and come
up with a great trip or some
unbelievable thing and then come up with
a crazy blessing for somebody and I
think that'll bring you down to earth
pretty quick
absolutely thanks have a great weekend
awesome thank you send us a postcard I
know remember those do you guys know
what a postcard is I don't know you're
always making fun of me of my old age I
am youthful I would like a postcard I
would like a postcard from Tracy for
Tracy Rachel and Ken here's where we
went had a great Lobster meal in Fiji
today thought you'd want a picture of it
oh I don't know what it is you know and
what's funny too I'm like you know with
I guess with a certain amount of money
and Dave says it all the time but he's
like you know once you eat you know too
much Lobster it can start to just taste
like soap like I like to try that
there's a point that like stuff is just
stuff and stuff is not wrong it is okay
to have nice stuff so we are definitely
not against that and just like we told
Tracy go and enjoy some of it yeah
um but man there's there's just nothing
like
hearing about a single mom yes who's
struggling and you just show up with a
car and you're like here you go oh
here's a toilet or there's a family you
know that's doing foster care and you
just go and show up with a thousand
dollar amazon gift card yes because
that's nothing for Tracy right now 700
000 a thousand dollars would freaking
change someone's life in that way right
so true I mean it's that kind of stuff
like take care of someone's Christmas oh
man it just had no hope at all I mean
you're exactly right there's so much fun
in that no five-star Resort that's going
to give you that feeling yes and uh and
I want you to do both right and that's
and that's the that's the fun of all of
this is that you you get to experience
but I think that you know when I talk to
a lot of people in the money space that
generosity piece oh is not always there
in teaching and so I do want all of you
listening to to to let that be a
motivation too right those of you that
are getting out of debt you know you're
in baby steps one through three and
you're pushing forward like go and enjoy
and have fun with your money use it as a
tool and enjoy it but also dream about
like man what are the what are the crazy
things we could do one day what if we
paid for someone's adoption like like
right like just have these These Dreams
show up and meet somebody and go hey
we're going to Fiji for the next 10 days
and uh we're taking you with us
you're not going to stay with us but
we'll take it let's just take it we'll
drop you off on the other side
well that's that's a good hour in the
books Ken thanks to everyone in the
booth all you gentlemen back there thank
you Ken this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting for
the PODS of moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I am Rachel Cruz
hosting this hour with Ramsay
personality and best-selling author and
host of the Ken Coleman show and Pullman
himself we are here to take your calls
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five it's a free call anywhere in
the country and we're here to to talk
talk and have a conversation about
what's going on in your life and you
know I was thinking about this can Dr
John zaloni talks about this a lot it's
just like the isolation of life and how
few people have good friends and we
always want to push you to have
relationships in life right to have
friendships in life but if there's
something that you're like man I just
need a second opinion on this here's
what I'm thinking I have some questions
that's what we're here for that's right
and let me point out too I'm here today
and we want to talk about your work too
if you feel like you're in a stagnant
stuck situation one of the greatest ways
to increase your income is a better job
David said for decades your income is
your greatest wealth building tool so
big shovel stuff I'd love to take those
questions you feel like you got a toxic
work situation can you get out of it
well get them in the baby steps any
angle from there Rachel and I will come
combine the advice there on the money
side and the work side I'd love to take
some of those questions uh trying to
figure out what you want to do with your
life anything in that area as well plus
the relationship plus the money
um and uh who knows maybe you can ask us
anything doesn't mean we'll answer it
I guess is that the way to put it yeah
yeah we'll try our best all right let's
go I'm standing by all right up next we
got Paul in San Antonio to start us off
this hour hey Paul welcome to the show
hello how are you we're doing well how
can we help
okay my mother is 89 years old with
dementia oh wow
okay I just moved moving bro I'm
actually moving her this week in a
nursing home
I sold her house after a walk away
paying tax and some dead Shield but um
ended up with 250 000 okay okay plus her
pension she gets 1900 a month now every
month I got to write a check to the
nursing home approximately four thousand
dollars okay okay
there's 250 000 that I have from the
house is going to pay for her nursing
home rather than just putting it in a
checking night uh to checking account
with her name with me power attorney
is there some way to do manage that
money where it can be making some
interest uh or because if we're just
sitting in a checking account doesn't
seem smart to me you know what what's
your idea on that what could I do yeah
that's a it's a great question so
um knowing her State and where she's at
she's 98 which she's lived an incredible
life well 89. oh 89 I'm so sorry I think
he said 98. 89 and
um and she how long has she had dementia
for
about three years okay okay I'm so sorry
that is so that's a that's a hard
a hard thing to watch a loved one my my
grandmother went through that
um
so you know we can't predict how long
she'll be there that's kind of what I'm
trying to do the math to to see you know
because because 50 yeah I mean you're
paying close to 50 Grand a year uh which
is great so meaning that she can she can
stay in this for years
um five years five years and so
um if I mean honestly Paul the way
everything's going right now you know
when you invest it's more thinking five
years or longer you're keeping your
money in the markets so doing anything
risky like that with this money makes me
nervous right now just again how
volatile the market is uh because it's
your it's such a short-term play for you
with this money uh meaning five years or
less and so I know it doesn't feel like
oh it's a good it's a good move just to
have it in a checking account uh but I
would probably honestly just put it in a
money market account so you're not going
to make a ton of interest but this money
isn't isn't here for the purpose of
making more money uh it's there to pay
her bills that she has to have in order
to stay there and so yeah she does she
does receive 1900 a month on her
retirement so yes she'll be getting 1900
a month so that's about half so actually
we'll be paying like about a little over
two thousand say 2100. yeah that's
that's true yes that's that's so true
yep yep
um but still honestly Paul I mean if I
were you I just wouldn't put it in
something that that it could it could
lose lose money in this because you
don't have the the the time frame to see
it play out over 20 years you know what
I'm saying and so if I were you having
that money accessible that I can get to
and I need it knowing it's there knowing
there's a predictable amount in there
that it's not fluctuating up and down
majorly would give me peace and I feel
like would honor her really well
um so again it's not flashy it's not
exciting but I don't think that's what
this money's for I think it's to help
keep her in a nursing home for um you
know for for as long as possible
you know I was thinking something some
kind of money market or something where
I yes I have the checking account to pay
her nursing home and say put like 50 000
or 50 000 every year yes that's right so
yeah a money market account would be a
great a great option so that's what I
would do uh but again you're not going
to see crazy Returns on that uh you'll
see a little bit you'll see more than a
traditional savings account or a
checking accounts but again that money
is there really more like an insurance
in a sense uh than an Investments so
that's the way I would look at it
okay yeah that's I really appreciate you
talking to me I've been wrecking my
brain on this you know she could die
tomorrow yeah or she could die in five
years
um you know but no matter what I don't
want them
money just all of us sitting in a
checking account not doing nothing you
know what I mean yes absolutely yep but
again I think that mindset of its uh
Insurance not an investment but a money
market account is what I would do and uh
my husband I we have a money Mark
account we just put some Savings in it's
where our emergency fund is and extra
money that we have every month and I
think we use Ally Bank it's an online
bank you know so there's some really
um accessible easy ways to sign up for a
money market account you can do your
local bank but um you can even find some
better rates possibly on an online bank
so not that we endorse Ally but that's
what we use in in it and it and it works
great yeah I think it's great advice
because you got a short-term situation
here we don't know how many years she's
going to have uh fewer rather than you
know longer obviously at this stage of
her life with what she's dealing with
and so it's you're right this is uh
let's make sure we use every every penny
of it to take care of her give her
comfort and dignity uh in these days you
know so and look the money market is
going to get you more than it ever has
uh yeah I should say that yeah more than
has recently that's right yes because of
where we're at with the interest rate so
it's a good place to park it and making
sure that her care is is well too
because that's a pretty inexpensive I
mean on average people are spending even
9 000 a month on on some nursing home
rooms for a single room so it's a very
very expensive play so it feels like
Paul though it's a very reasonable price
that you gave me I was expecting it to
be a lot more so I'm thankful for that
and again that half of it is covered
with um with the checks that she gets as
well so I hope that helps Paul thank you
uh but can I mean that that stuff is
hard that's why long-term care insurance
is a is a is an important thing to play
you know like when there's all these
parts of our money that you look at
um at different stages of life whether
it's life insurance uh getting a will
like all these things looking at that at
that as a big picture is a is an
important play so absolutely thanks Paul
thanks for the call this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsay
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
week for our brand new gazelle debit
card this debit card will help you spend
and save the Ramsay way the gazelle
debit card works the same as your
standard debit card with the same FDIC
protections and no we're not becoming a
bank but we have partnered with password
n a member FDIC to provide banking
services behind the scenes so that means
that we can offer the same FDIC
protections and you will not be flooded
with debt and credit card offers so
there's no junk mail from us so the
gazelle comes with a debit card spending
out account and mobile app and it also
connects to every dollar seamlessly so
you know exactly where your budget
stands and where your money is going so
it is free to create an account and
there's no monthly fees to maintain your
accounts and no overdraft so there are
no overdraft fees which banks make
billions on over here it's insane so our
team is continuing to add new features
like joint accounts Apple pay and more
all with the goal to help you reach your
money goals fast this is really really
exciting it is so beautiful the gazelle
card and just a point of conversation
you know when you
when you pull out the gazelle card
people are like what is that yeah so
good point because it looks great I was
telling I was telling Dave yesterday
that like the the benefit of this card
is if you if you're just kind of liberal
with how you move your hand and arm
around when you're using it at the
grocery store people are going to see it
and be like what's that what the heck is
that and you get to talk about what you
do and how you live and with your mom
when you see other people with it it's a
great looking cart yeah it is speaking
of fees I I got to tell you are you done
also go to ramseysolutions.com gazelle
to sign up for your free accounts again
ramsaysolutions.com
I'm very excited to run this by you I I
did not tell James the producer about
this but uh he'll be okay so I was
talking about this on on the Ken Coleman
show today and I gotta get your take on
it okay
so there is a lawyer she is a consumer
Advocate lawyer okay out of Hawaii okay
and she is suing
uh Romano's Macaroni Grill the
restaurant chain because she went to eat
there recently and she looked at her
receipt her bill when she was getting
ready to sign and they charged her a
three dollar inflation fee
they didn't tell her this when she came
to eat some pasta and she's suing them
thank you and and she's like this is
crazy bake it into the price
I'm just telling you take it in I don't
know I like what you're doing there but
but restaurant she goes restaurants are
doing this more and more and if you're
not paying attention to it they they
come up with a term for a fee and it's a
feed you were talking about Banks and
fees yes and it made me think about this
and so I want to warn the people
because she is suing him she's going
this is a call from the Mountaintop Ken
I'm just selling from The Mountaintop
I'm just saying you better look at your
receipt because if macaroni Grill's
doing it somebody else is doing it and
so they're charging an inflation fee now
here's the deal restaurants can do
anything they want it's their business
I'm all for that yes yes all I'm saying
is when I show up and I'd say a party of
five please I would like them to say oh
by the way are you aware that we are now
charging you a three dollar inflation
fee I don't want to find out about it
after taking my fill of bread and pasta
yes yes do you think that that's right
that they don't tell you about it I I
think it's not a smart
because everywhere Winston I just went
on a date night on Wednesday night we
looked at the prices and again Nashville
I guess can be bougie we were at a
pretty like Standard Restaurant I'd say
but it's just expect like we even
laughed like oh my God like you it's
just a lot like what an entree cost so I
wouldn't Flinch at my entree being an
extra
dollar right fair and so put it in the
so I just think it's bad business it is
a three dollar inflation fee I mean how
stupid do we do these people think we
are we're just gonna go oh well that
makes a lot of sense no you just hit me
for three dollars for nothing I mean
that's not even a real feat you just
pulled that out of here you know what
and I got to tell you I told my audience
I said let me tell you there's two ways
to go let me just tell me Ken you can go
in and ask them
I just need to know before I take my
seat
do you have an inflation fee or some
kind of no you do that no no I wouldn't
do that I've given people who are
non-convertational that option oh yes
I'm confrontational I love a good
confrontation I'm waiting until the bill
comes and I'm doing this number and I'm
looking at it and I'm looking I go okay
I can see there I got the antipasto I'm
gonna I see that I go oh excuse me
ma'am sir come over here what what is
this and the waiter tells you to go I'd
like to I'd like you we have two options
here either you can tell your manager
I'm not paying for it or you can send
your manager over here and I'm going to
tell them that I'm not paying for it
that's what I would do that's what you
would do someone has to stand up against
the fees of the People by the people for
the people of a man of the people I'm
just saying just say it's ridiculous I
know but the thing is is you wouldn't
think it's ridiculous so they baked it
into the price of your food it's not the
scenario I'm bringing in I know I'm
saying that you have to fight for your
finances people three dollars here three
dollars there that kills your budget
before you know it I'm just telling you
James somebody has everything is not
working this is a great tease because
we're actually doing a fine print
episode next season all about Macaroni
Grill so we are oh well listen nothing
against it I believed you Hey listen I
like dick I like to frequent that joint
they got good food but I'm going in
there and believe you me I'm going hey
party of five please okay here's what's
fascinating to me though that she was so
she sued them
suit them I like it like you go to lost
that you go I like it now I think I just
pay the fee I don't have time okay I
don't have time in my life I want to
make sure that the people hear what's
happening to deal with that I'm
anti-inflation Rachel's like I don't
care I have so much Financial Peace that
I don't care about I went to Olive
Garden and it was an extra two bucks I
am not gonna think I'm gonna lawyer up I
didn't I said go around suing people
that's I just told her though I just
said I I can't believe she went down the
road I would just pay it and now you're
saying well Rachel it just pay us you
don't care about it inflation I'll tell
you why I like it she's an actual lawyer
so she's not like oh that's fair okay I
like that it's her Lane and she's kind
of standing up for the people yeah no I
hear you I hear you and she was I think
it's three dollar inflation fee
I mean it's ridiculous okay so what
should they do so let's say macaroni you
know what can we just talk about the
situation I have an answer well good so
if macaroni girl said I am not going to
raise our prices because it is so you
know we're gonna figure out how to do
this to help the people sure we're not
raising prices everyone else says we're
not going to right but to offset hourly
wages to offset the price of food the
gas that's in the trucks that deliver
the food are charging us more we're just
getting charged more to run business
today which is what's happening yeah so
if every customer pays an extra three
bucks it helps us keep the food costs
down of what the customer has to pay
and it's great how about
how about you come out and say you know
what we as Macaroni Grill are not going
to charge you a three dollar inflation
fee here's what we're going to do we're
going to keep prices the same because we
know that everybody wants to go out and
have a nice meal every once in a while
so we're going to be the restaurant
chain who doesn't Jack our prices
because as a corporation we make a good
amount of money and we'd love for you to
support us now you know what happened
everybody would go but let's go to
Macaroni Grill and everybody's going to
tip the waiters and waitresses very
nicely well I see on the board here Rick
has something about restaurants are
getting discounts oh this is talk radio
Okay live reaction Rick Rick are you
hearing us chat about Macaroni Grill
yes I did how you doing today good great
let's say you Rick
um what a lot of restaurants around here
are doing which I'm surprised they
didn't do it in the beginning because
anytime you use a card those businesses
are getting charged by the people that
process the payments yep yep so what the
restaurants are doing around here
there's been two or three of them here
in our area locally here that uh what
they're doing is if you pay cash you pay
a cheaper rate and they're basically if
you use a card then they're passing that
payment on so that's a way for them not
to have great prices
too love it that is see now that's
innovation without sticking it to the
little guy who just wants some
breadsticks you know
that's so good Rick
thanks for calling in on that because
that's a great thank you Rick so
restaurants out there yeah Rick makes an
excellent point
inflation everybody Stand Together take
your Rachel Cruz wallet take out the out
to eat money add the cash and you get
charged look what you did there then if
you used a card because there's no fees
for the merchant all right see this is
how we fight inflation how do we how do
we think through this America you know
what we ought to do James 30 days
all Americans decide we're only going to
eat stuff in our house we're gonna go on
a spending freeze watch Target Walmart
Kroger and all of them drop prices
stick that in your pipe and smoke it
this might be the only thing that can
unite America
United again Ken and Rachel for America
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
are taking your calls about your money
your career your relationships anything
and everything triple eight eight two
five five two two five up next is Karina
in Boise hey Karina welcome to the show
hi thank you yeah absolutely how can we
help
so last week me and my fiance broke up
because we couldn't decide on finances
and also more importantly we couldn't
decide on how to inherit our kids
he has two boys and we're gonna have one
son and I have a paid for house and I
make a bit more money than him
and he has a house with some equity in
it but he has a roommate on the title
and mortgage because they invested
together
and then um so I am
I am Christian and I know God wants us
to put our spouse before our children
but I think in our arguments I was just
having such a hard time
and um you know I haven't I haven't been
with my fiance but it's like for a week
but just moving forward with him or
without him I need to figure it out for
the next time that this comes up about
and you know figure out how to how to
deal with it you know do you guys share
children children are your children from
different folks you share them what
what's the situation
oh yeah he has two boys with his first
wife okay and I have a son and I pretty
much raised him alone
um his father was not involved okay
gotcha okay yeah and what was the
disagreement about Karina
so I think
um I it all started when I mentioned to
him that when I moved into my house
which is paid off
um I I wanted to leave years as an
inheritance to my son because
I
think
um I sacrificed a lot of quality time
when my son was little
um because I was going to school for
engineering and I was single and I was
working so I didn't get to spend that
quality time with him and when I finally
got that stability I wanted to give it
to him kind of to make up for what I
couldn't do before so it's really
emotional for me to talk about finances
and um my my ex-fiance he wasn't
understanding that and um and I to this
point I get it like
um
your spouse should come first but in
terms of finances I'm just having a hard
time dealing with that yeah did you
um did you initiate the breakup or did
he
um it was just kind of
Mutual we
tired of
the Oreos and how we can make it work
and we both argued our points like I
know he wants to protect his children
and um and I want to protect my son in
terms of you know what we have
established already
um so
so what's your question what's your
question for us specifically
like how
how can how do you go about finances in
like a second relationship when you
already bring in children
do you know like because how old are the
kids this inherit them how do you just
not get married yeah my son is 21. okay
and then his kids he has a 13 year old
and a 15 year old okay so no I I I let
Rachel take the bigger Crux of the
relationship and money but he's 21 and
he has a 15 year old
um no my son is 21. my fiance is oh my
gosh I'm so sorry I thought you meant he
has more he as in your fiance I'm sorry
I apologize yeah I I just wanna I wanna
point out something that's come up twice
in the conversation with us and I just
want to get that out of the way and let
Rachel kind of help you on this and and
I can weigh in on the matter and stuff
too but
this idea that the Bible says that you
you value your spouse of your kids this
idea that that means you disinherit your
son no no no no no no
this this is all going to fall under the
same umbrella that Rachel's going to
advise you on on y'all being on the same
page and it doesn't matter if the kids
are coming in from previous
relationships or not but no no under no
scenario are you going to disavow or as
you're saying disinherit your son uh
that's not part of the equation and if
that's part of the conversation it's not
healthy and you did the right thing by
walking
yeah and Karina for you as a mom
um because I can only imagine the
sacrifices that you made when he was
little and that's where a lot of this
emotion is coming from
and so I feel like I would I would I
would kind of challenge you to say you
know this is a symbol this house is a
symbol of your hard work you feeling
guilty probably a level of mom guilt of
leaving your son when he was younger and
it's excruciating you know when I have
to leave my kids I had a four-year-old
crying in the garage when I pulled out
to come to this show like it's it's not
it's not fun like it is it is hard as a
mom
uh for those working and that you're
like oh and so you as a single mom
especially
went through so much Karina so much in
order to have this but I I would I would
just challenge you not that this would
change your decision but I want you to
if you can separate this house and what
you did for your son and the
relationship you have with your son this
house has become a symbol
um and I don't want it to be the make or
break breaking point for you in the
future with relationships and I and I
understand that it's to protect this for
your son
um but just as a mom I don't want you to
carry that burden of still feeling like
I have to I have to make up for what I
did because Karina you did what you had
to do you were a single mom and that's
that was the situation you were in and
so that you're not a bad mom for doing
this so giving your house a son or not
giving your your son a house or not
doesn't make you a good or bad mom
um so I want you to kind of separate
that that language in your head because
I feel like that's Twisted into this
decision does that make sense
yes
um because I I under and I and I and I
applaud you for
um being so protective of it because
again I I I hear what you walk through
with it so it makes sense but I also
don't want this house to be the symbol
of what I did and I feel bad and now I
have to make it up to my son because you
know what your son wants Karina he wants
you and and and if he wants his mom to
be happy if this man that you love
um your your ex-fiance you know if there
if if that is a relationship that is
good for you and it is healthy
um and you guys can find the way to to
reconcile these two things or this thing
of The Inheritance which is a big deal
but but also at the end of the day like
there's a point too of companionship and
love in a marriage
um that's the question I have Karina and
pardon me for I was trying to listen are
you guys on the same page with debt and
everything else
or is there also some some separation in
the way he sees money and debt and all
that stuff because you've done
everything the right way where are you
guys on the rest of the stuff the rest
of the money stuff
she she's good with money and um
yeah he's very smart with money and I
don't think there there's an issue there
I think it's just more about
combining combining households and
um you know is he on the same page with
you and I'm bringing in one right but
let me ask you this is he on the same
page in relation to debt that's yes or
no
yes okay is he is he also on the same
page that when we come together as a
married couple we combine our finances
yes he is more for that
for that he he said that we should
combine everything
and um at the end of the day we just
split it up like when we both passed
away we just split it up evenly between
all our kids okay all right all right so
I'm the one that's kind of like selfish
because I'm I'm like I'm bringing in
more and he has two kids and I have one
kid yeah but Rachel's right I hope you
heard Rachel uh I'm telling you she's
right so I I got to tell you I'm taking
a little bit different attack here I
think you guys need to have a nice
dinner
and I think you guys need to sit down
and get this hashed out and say what
really matters and let's look at the big
picture and you're gonna have to let go
of some stuff I love Rachel's advice
there I don't know I want to see her I
want to see her give this a chance I
know because I feel like this is just
about the investment throughout when it
becomes this this thing and we don't
want our stuff to own us and at that
point it's owning a part of you for good
reason I understand it but I want you to
have freedom from that and I think it's
attached to that Mom Gail Karina that I
really want you to think through so
thank you for calling I hope that helps
and and you know I hope you guys
um Can can go the way that you need to
go whether it's together or separate
thanks for calling
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting it today with Ramsay
personality investing author Ken Coleman
going to the phones will in St Louis is
up next hey Will welcome to the show
hi guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
um I have a career question I work for a
medical device company I work in a very
small
Department of that company there's four
of us for the uh whole country
and
um a couple of days ago I presented
uh business plan
um to the VP that uh
identified some gaps in our department
and how to fix them and make it uh
work better for the company as a whole
and in that business plan it created a
new
manager role
and uh this morning
um I got off the phone with him and he
wants me to take over
that new manager role that my business
Plan called for nice
and
um
now I'm just extremely nervous and
scared I felt like I'm going to throw up
all day yeah hey be careful what you
wish for at one of those deals huh
yeah so I I've never been in the
leadership role before and um like I
said it's a very small team I'm actually
the newest person on this team okay
um so you would be you would be leading
three other people if I heard that right
yes okay all right so what's your
question I I can't wait to answer it
um just how do I transition from so I've
been on this team for five months so I
am the newest guy right how do I
transition from being the new guy to
being a leader and
um making this huge jump that I I've
never attempted before yeah okay great
question you ready yeah you got
something to take notes with because I
might have you write a couple things
down you ready
yes absolutely all right so you have
worked how long in in a professional
environment how long you've been an
employee
I've been in the medical device
um arena for five and a half years all
right so five and a half years you've
been a follower yes or no
yes yes and so you've probably had some
good leaders uh you've probably had some
bad leaders maybe you've had some uh
average leaders is that true
yes okay so one of the exercises I want
you to go through the next couple days
and preferably tonight start with this
is I want you to write down uh all of
the things uh that that you would leave
that you would say I've worked under
good leaders and these are the good
attributes these are the things that
that I remember seeing and thinking that
was a good leader that was that was good
leadership and then I want you to do uh
the opposite and say okay when I work
for a bad leader this is what they did
that I thought was bad and it wasn't
good and this is just you kind of as a
follower you know what good leadership
looks like you know what bad leadership
looks like and I want you to just write
it down and go okay so now I remember
and I've got some experience that's the
first thing the second homework
assignment
um that I want you to think through is
is I want you uh I want you to think
through
um what you think now because you came
up with this whole business plan and you
you came up with this idea of a manager
now they're going to give you the role
and I want you to to ask yourself this
question if I were in the other three
people's shoes
how would I want
me to treat them like so put you put
yourself in your their shoes and go wait
a second I'm the new guy and now I'm
going to be in a leadership position if
I were in their shoes and I had a new
guy come in and all of a sudden he was
my leader how would I want to be treated
do you understand that question
yes all right write that down all right
now those are the two homework
assignments and that's going to put you
in the right uh place I think from a
posture towards how I'm going to treat
people now there's some basic exercises
that I tell new leaders because
everybody's scared to become a leader
when you haven't LED before but I think
if you do two things every week will
every week
I think you could become a tremendous
leader and these are the two things and
even if they're remote I want you to do
these two things every week the first
thing is I want you to get on a regular
schedule once a week at minimum asking
your team the three people how are they
doing personally this is not a how you
doing in the hallway as a greeting this
is hey how are you doing how's life
learn about their their marriage their
kids their mom and dad's Health learn
everything you can about them and you're
asking them on a regular basis how are
you doing now listen leaders that's a
personal question
how are you doing you might get some
personal answers you're going to get
some personal answers but you this is
where you begin to build a relationship
with them and they learn that you care
now the second question is how can I
help you win in your role
how can I help you win in your old
that's it you say it however you want to
but those are the that's the heart of
the question so the first question is a
relationship question and the second
question is a servant-based leadership
question how can I help you win well I
need this or this has been happening I
think we need to look at the front okay
great let me see if I can get in and
make change and those two questions are
going to help you develop Trust
and then credibility too many young
leaders try to go in Rachel and
establish credibility when certainly in
this situation where you're the new guy
maybe you have some older co-workers and
all of a sudden you're the new green
leader and they're kind of looking at
you kind of going on what's the story
here whose butt did he kiss to get here
and there's all that cynicism they try
to win on credibility and you cannot win
on credibility until you win
relationally yes win relationally first
professionally next I could probably
take over your job Ken you know why I
wrote a few things now as you're talking
I was like what am I because I'm not a
I'm you followed though I have I have
Kate I have a brand leader yeah you do
who reports to Jerry brilliant
appointment right so like what would you
say we're in the chain of commands I
thought what makes what the leaders I've
had working what do I love about them
like what makes them a leader I put
personal in the question what can I do
for you you're kidding me literally look
at that that's incredible folks I'm not
kidding will when I feel like she knows
what's going on and it's been you know a
hard season with the kids or something
and she asks okay so how was so and so
this morning how did she do I'm like oh
thank you for just knowing me because it
may be a hard morning and I just
appreciate your acknowledgment that's it
and then when they ask hey how what do
you need from me
it is like the most humble question
because a lot of leaders
in a toxic way feel like what can you do
for me because I'm leading this thing
well let's flip that first it's like
when you're a servant leader and you
truly are like hey I'm actually going to
serve you as my team like that is a
that's a paradox that people are not
used to well and people will be loyal to
you because man that's hard to find so
let me flip that right as in Rachel
scenario there if as a leader new leader
current leader whatever if you ask the
how can I help you win in your job
question and you've not established the
personal relationship guess what people
are afraid to tell you because they feel
like if I tell you what I need you're
going to think that I'm weak that I
can't do the job and you may fire me but
when you lead with the personal and you
say how are you doing and the the
employee feels as though you know them
see them as Rachel said and then they
trust you because of the relational
connection then they're gonna go well
I'm glad you asked me hey Will there's
three guys on the team or three people
yes yes you know what I would do I would
take that are you married will
I am okay I would take you and your wife
and take each of them separately out to
dinner and if they're married bring
their spouse
there's just three of them I love you
have to do 20 dinners because there's
not many of them begin to build a
relationship and just be like hey I want
to take you guys out to dinner and kind
of get to know you guys on a personal
note and like that that jump starts that
personal connection by the way I want to
point out will I don't know if you've
been listening to the entire hour but I
wouldn't take them to Macaroni Grill
you're gonna get hit with the inflation
food
I'm bringing in some some people from my
work it's a corporate dinner man am I
gonna get hit with the inflation fee
what are all your thoughts on all of
that that can just Ken just gave you
what do you think
I like it yeah it's it's an interesting
um take on it I've never thought of it
that way
will coming you can lead
you can lead because you can love people
we got too many leaders who don't know
how to love the people that they're
trying to lead yep it's not that hard
folks that's right
well
that hour's in the books what's the old
saying at this hour of the books is that
I like this gesture is it a little
gesture gentleman in the booth thank you
for all your hard work Ken always great
to be with you this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I am Rachel Cruz hosting this
hour with best-selling author and hosts
the king Coleman show Ramsay personality
in Holmen and we're taking your calls on
life money relationships anything and
everything going on we are here for you
and it's a free call anywhere in the
country at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
so our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window covering you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
Ramsay to get the best deal today's
question comes from Kelsey in Wyoming my
husband is a loyal Ramsay show listener
after I tried to get him on board for
years and we are on our
Financial Journey towards home ownership
we are so close and I am making many
sacrifices but my husband won't make the
one huge sacrifice that would get us in
a home ASAP he has a work truck
that he can use for all driving and
we're still keeping his fun car she's
got fun in quotes oh boy that's got some
emotion uh wrapped around that one
whenever you go to the old quote Oh Boy
the cost of the car includes paying
Insurance maintenance switching out
seasonal tires Etc
while it maybe gets driven once a month
boy maybe he's in all caps the tension
is building as I read this folks uh the
way the used car market is and the Kelly
Blue Book value we could excuse me we
would be able to finish funding our down
payment with the sale of this car he
will not entertain this idea our rent is
also being raised in current projection
have us taking another two years to save
up help please oh boy oh man wow layers
layers here's one thing I've learned
though you can't make anyone do anything
it's like so Kelsey you're either gonna
have to become really persuasive oh boy
um
because like you can't just
yeah what are you gonna do like make him
sell it like but but so so what do you
do what do you do I would get underneath
really like your goals what you guys
want and that's that that's the idea is
getting on the same page so I was gonna
say if you would have your down payment
saved up in six months let it go let it
go Kelsey Let It Go and just save up and
do the down payment but two years that
would frustrate me that would be hard
everyone's being raised and I'm like man
so I'm gonna so you know what I'm gonna
do I'm I okay so I'm all right if I'm
her
I'm not going to keep you know fighting
the whole cellular precious car okay so
I'm gonna go all right
I get it I'm not going to keep trying to
create more attention I want to try to
get you to sell your car I know you'll
love your car whatever whatever
but I don't want to wait two more years
our rent's going up
so if you won't sell the car what will
you do meet me in the middle if I let go
of a car yep what will you do will you
work another job that's what I do I I
would take the car off the table and
then he relaxes he takes a deep breath
and I know how dudes are wired he thinks
he gets a win there
and right when he starts to get
comfortable here you go but
we gotta do something you gotta give me
something give me something man yeah and
he needs to know too like
for me if I was in that situation you
start to feel like he loves this car
more than our future
wow it's a little bit how it feels
though it feels like if we are if if we
are working this plan together we know
what we want we want to be in a house
financially it makes more sense to be in
a house than to have a rent raised for
two years you're choosing your thing
over like where we could be like she's
not asking to take the money from the
used car and go buy like or the car and
go buy purses with it right like 100
wait a second this is I'm so glad you
said this because we gotta unpack this I
agree with everything you said except
for the nuclear option there you went
nuclear and you can't that's what it
feels like yeah but you can't say that
to him because you're going to push him
away even further he's gonna then he's
gonna feel no look look we got a guy out
in the lobby shaking his head listen no
and the lady's going she may not feel it
and I'm not gonna put that on couch
let's say that
you can't say you can't say it feels
like you disagree you can't see it she
feels that I'm not saying she does Let's
Pretend she does let's pretend that the
way I would that I could be like man
that would be really hard and that would
be really hard it would be it'd be very
frustrating I totally get that if I'm
feeling that I 1 000 would say that to
Winston in a respectful way but I'm like
babe this is what matter he doesn't hear
respect you're not being known in your
marriage Ken if you cannot communicate
what you're feeling say that what you're
feeling no you could say I'm feeling
frustrated and I know I came after you
I'm gonna tell you now we cannot have a
conversation like this
I don't think you can say that to the
guy because then you make him defensive
what I said was I agree that he needs to
make a sacrifice but if it's not that it
needs to be something else and she needs
to say I'm feeling frustrated and I'm
feeling like you aren't as committed to
getting in the house as as fast as I am
and I'm frustrated about a rent going up
and you so you know what I did come at
you in the car but I don't want there to
be tension between us but I'm asking you
you got to meet me in the middle you got
to come somewhere else that's what I'm
saying I don't say it feels like you
love the car more than me that's
horrible thing to say okay let me say
this number one I agree with everything
you said and I think that's a great
option but also if I if she feels that
way though if Kelsey feels that way
which I'm totally putting this on Kelsey
I think it is a I think that is healthy
if John zaloney was sitting in here Dr
annoying he would say my because it
because it triggers a fear it trigger it
like stuff oh it triggers it triggers
him all right and it's not and it's not
a difference that's right and it's not a
disrespectful thing but if I don't have
the freedom to be able to communicate
that to myself you didn't have the
freedom you better not say that I said
don't I said don't say that I gave you a
much nicer Hallmark healthy relationship
man no no no okay seriously in all
seriously you really believe that if you
say to your husband you love this object
that he cares about more than you I
could say that doesn't trigger him and
here's what I would say no here's what I
would say I would say man this is man
hey man uh I this is how I've
communicated I would just say I don't
know I'm thinking off the cuff here
um that for our family and what our
goals are in life that we could be there
so much sooner that's very different
than what you did I'm not done and
because we're not wanting it you're
holding on to something that can push us
forward and what in underneath that if
we're going a level deeper it feels like
it's it's choosing like gosh the future
or this thing and walk me through that
let me I want to hear from you
uh you know what you're seeing what what
is the value that this car is brings I
want to know that about you like I want
to know why this is this but this is
what's going on in me I think that is
that that is marriage to me that's
marriage so I don't disagree with all of
that version that version was a little
bit like less nuclear than the whole it
feels like you love the car more than me
that does not help I just don't care I
didn't say it like that no you did but
the sentiment you have to you have to
communicate that though that because
there's a step back because I do think I
can see that there's stuff under that
like it sucks listen I agree with you I
just you don't want to put him on the
defensive you want him to meet you in
the middle and the way you say it your
tone is everything so you can't go
bicker no I don't think that but for me
to tell you hey here's here's ultimately
what I'm feeling and it and and I'm
fearful in that like help me with that
like let's talk through that that's I
would say I think it's okay to say I
don't feel like you are as intentional
and as excited about getting the house
as I am I wouldn't say you love
something more than me that's all I'm
saying maybe not those words but it
could be the fear and if it's the fear
she needs to communicate it okay I love
it good stuff we're not marriage
counselors let's just throw that out
there all right this is
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show Ken and
I are still debating even during the
commercial segment that's okay not true
we're not debating we're looking at the
finer points of the conversation anyways
just to conclude we both agree we both
agree he needs to sell the car get into
the house later you can buy another car
oh no he's shaking his head no we're
getting some mixed from the lobby well
you know what's interesting we ran into
a couple that's sitting out in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions who went through a
similar scenario and she's a
psychiatrist and full disclosure he did
sell the car but then he got it back
later yes so that's an interesting tack
that I did not think of initially didn't
think about it well so you know it was
good good discussion it's always good
what say you America chime in triple
8825-5225 we were talking about this
that's fair if you agree or not yeah we
had Rick call in with a real time look
folks Austin this is your show let's
have some opinions Austin let's move the
phone lines around let's go the people
want to speak let's go they want to
speak this is your show all right next
we do have Natalie though waiting in
Colorado Springs hey Natalie welcome to
the show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely thanks for calling how can we
help
um next August my husband will retire
from active duty and transition to a new
career oh wow thank you guys for both of
your services thank you
oh you're so welcome we have extra
savings over and above our emergency
fund should we save this money for for
the transition or spend slash put it
towards the house
how much is it how much is above the
emergency fund
uh we have about 6 30 000 in our
emergency fund and then we have another
22
000 just kind of sitting there okay
uh and when and when will he be back did
you say or he'll um retire August of
2023 okay so it's still yeah uh how much
is left on your house
uh 380 380 okay
and any other debt
no no
uh are you are you guys investing 15
yeah we have yeah we have about 500 000
in retirement oh wow and then another
another small investment about forty six
thousand amazing you know Natalie if I
were you I would just go ahead and throw
it at the house
um you guys have a great emergency
fundament you have sixty three thousand
dollars and if there is some time for
transition when he gets out to
transitioning to something else you know
you you guys have
um the the funds there if you need it uh
right but above and beyond that yeah I
would go ahead and I would and throw it
at the house
so that brings up my second question
he's wanting to get a camper and Jeep
like a different vehicle uh and camper
I'm wanting to throw this money at our
house that
um and I know you've all run typically
you advise 50 of your annual income and
our annual gross income is about 150
000.
um
not to be in Motors and wheels is what
you're clarifying yeah
yes and how much would the camper be
um we're looking at probably after we
trade in a vehicle probably at least
another 40 000 to get into what he's
looking at okay and then how much would
the Jeep be
well it would be it would be a larger
SUV but
um
total to
tal to get into a camper and a larger
SUV would be about forty thousand so
let's go together I'm sorry leaning
towards that right now oh okay okay okay
I hear you
um are you guys throwing any extra at
the house
per month we only throw 300 a month
extra extra there okay okay
um
I mean for what you guys are saving at
the pace you're saving will you guys
have that 40 000 when he gets back from
um
when he or when he retires in August
no
no you won't so you'll have to continue
to save
yeah okay okay
um I don't think he gets both
he's got to choose
right I agree and that's that's where
we're separated I would like to throw it
at the house and keep camping and he
would like to like our kids are growing
up and he wants to get the camper and
the vehicle now okay and see now this is
where we got to go after this what he
wants like I want to dunk a basketball
in a 10-foot goal ain't happening uh you
know and so driving around all the time
may not be realistic but we could maybe
rent in an RV every once in a while I
have some friends that just did that
with their kids yeah they saved up for
it you know and and so they went and
they had a great time drove all across
the country and then they dropped it off
and they didn't have to spend you know
twenty thousand or thirty thousand or
ten thousand whatever so you know
wanting to Camp wanting to make memories
I get that but he's got to choose he's
got to choose this is uh this is a
relationship and you got to go look I'm
for it but I really want this and so
what are we going to do we can still
camp out nice tents and we can maybe
rent the occasional RV and and make some
memories but drop it off uh because
that's a uh an asset that you know I
wouldn't spend a lot of money on a
camper I just wouldn't yeah for sure so
yeah my my focus would be you know he
can get you know one one thing whether
it's upgrading the car and then I would
throw the rest yeah at the house Natalie
and once you guys have this house paid
off uh which will be a few you know
years uh then you can really save up a
lot yeah and faster when you don't have
a mortgage payment to go and do all
those luxury things so
um yeah I I agree with Ken on that one
so that's great can't have it all can't
have it all well you can but not at the
same time maybe maybe we say all of it
yep all right up next we got Samantha in
West Virginia hey Samantha welcome to
the show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
um so I was divorced in 2014
um and I had have two children and I
purchased a home before
the tax season rolled around and the way
my ex-husband paid my portion of the
house that I put into a new house was
through
his 401k which cost a lot of taxes um
when tax season rolled around so it
ended up me putting a lot of things on
credit cards so
um I was buying things for the house for
my kids and I put it to have a lot of
credit card debt I'm remarried now so
I'm a very wonderful supportive husband
and he definitely supports me wanting to
pay off my debt we don't have combined
finances and we've been married for six
and a half years and I haven't tackled
any of this debt I worked part-time I
was a stay-at-home mom before I got my
divorce so I I hear I've been reading
um The Total Money Makeover and my
husband and I are reading smart money
kids so I'm trying to kind of change
what I've been doing yeah it's awesome
so Samantha what have you been doing for
work in the last two and a half years in
your new marriage have you been home
still with the kids
I was working part-time and then this
past year now I'm working full-time okay
okay
um so yeah we've had a lot of
relationship calls on the show this this
uh today and yeah I mean I'm gonna
continue to go back Samantha to what
we've said it's even past callers today
but
um yeah getting on the same page is it
is it's so crucial when you combine even
from a you know logistical standpoint
when you combine your checking accounts
and you guys are working as one that
speaks magnitude to what you guys how
one you guys are that's just like kind
of a symbol uh a data point to say okay
if we can combine accounts and we're
working on the same checking account and
when a paycheck hits whether I'm
full-time part-time he's full-time
whatever it is the money hits the
account it is ours we are one there's a
level of commitment a level of intimacy
a level of richness that really happens
when you say we really really are gonna
lock arms and be a team even with our
money and so he's probably hesitant
maybe because it was the credit card
debt before you know you came in and but
um do you feel like with money would you
say how you've acted so far in the
marriage with money that you can be
trustworthy like have you established
good money habits
oh absolutely yeah so so yeah so for me
it'd be different if you're like yeah I
kept racking up credit card debt and
last month I racked up two thousand
dollars you know I'd be like yeah I
understand why he doesn't want to like
combine because you guys aren't too so
totally separate places so
um hold on the line Samantha Austin's
gonna pick up and give you guys
Financial Peace University for a year
and uh in every dollar our budgeting app
to start working together because it's
crucial crucial Samantha that you guys
work together when you do then I think
that trust transfers and he's going to
be more on the same page of saying hey
together we're going to tackle this debt
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting with Ramsay
personality and bestselling author Ken
Coleman the best in the business when it
comes to helping people in their career
and you just have so many great tools
too Ken that that help people really get
on this path of understanding well thank
you what what they're good at and what
they what they need to be doing yeah
we've got a great assessment that's only
ten dollars for just a few more days
it's been a 10 sale on this assessment
called the get clear assessment here's
the quick version of what it does it
allows you to get self-awareness in
three key areas what you're good at
that's your talent the work you really
love to do that's passion and then the
results that motivate you that's Mission
and so when you can get clear on all
three of those unique elements of who
you are and we put it together in a
purpose statement that allows you to see
at a high level hey this is purposeful
work this is Meaningful work in other
words I was created to do this it allows
you to have Clarity and confidence it's
about a 20-minute assessment it's only
ten dollars it's called the get clear
assessment it's only ten dollars for a
few more days uh at ramsesolutions.com
so good it's great I've known a few
people that have taken it just in my own
personal life Ken Yeah we actually
shared Dave's results yesterday
yeah spent a whole segment on it and
read his purpose statement out and
walked through that and uh yeah yeah
it's it's a it's a fun tool for a
teenager maybe trying to figure out what
they want to do maybe that young adult
who hasn't quite found that thing or
maybe for your spouse or loved one or
friend or whatever uh but yeah it's it's
a fun awareness tool for sure I went
through it with your brother-in-law yes
Bill he was in my head too of yeah one
of the people that I know that all it
does is give you a mirror and lets you
see yourself uniquely as the world sees
you as your creator sees you and it's a
fun little tool so good yep all right up
next we have Tiara in Cleveland hi
Tierra welcome to the show
hi thank you both for taking my call
today absolutely how can we help
so I just bought out my lease which I
know is a big No-No now but I'm not
quite sure what to do with it from this
point on
my car as a whole I can sell it for
about 25
000 and I owe 14 000 on it so I was
thinking of doing that and just using
what I get back from that to just buy a
used car in full or if I should apply
that to credit cards or something I'm
really yeah not sure no it's a great
question a great question
um well I'm thankful yeah you'll be able
to get about nine thousand dollars for
it
um which is which is great so what other
debt do you have you mentioned credit
cards how much do you have in credit
card
13 000 in credit cards okay
um 31 000 in student loans okay
and then the car is 14 000 remaining
there okay perfect any other debt or is
that it
that's it okay that's great and the
credit cards are there multiple cards
that equal that thirteen thousand or is
it one where
it's three but the majority of it is all
one okay we're about two okay
that's great so
um
yeah Tierra I mean I answer these
questions a lot of if I just woke up in
your shoes what would I what would I do
and I would definitely sell the car uh
how much sorry how much do you make a
year to just to throw those numbers in
uh 52 000 okay
so
if I were you I would um I would sell
this car I would get a
three thousand four thousand dollar car
not a great car but I would pay cash for
for what we call a beater just a car to
get you to and from where you need to go
and then take the remainder of that so
another five thousand of that that
you'll get from the car and start
throwing it at these credit cards and
start working your way out
um
so tell me like when you you called the
show and so I know you're kind of at
this point of change what has happened
recently for you to be like wow I
because you could just keep this 20 you
know this 14 000 car loan and keep going
but you you're the one that even said I
could sell it uh what What's caused some
of your shift when it comes to the way
you handle your money
um I'm just tired of paying payments
amen I don't want all of my heart earned
no need to just keep going towards that
payment yeah I just don't think it's
worth it anymore so good and Tierra I'm
excited to hear you say that because for
a lot of people that's when change
occurs you know we always say it's the
AHA moments this moment that you just
look up and you think all the money that
I've been working for is going to a bank
I don't get to keep it it is leaving me
and never again never again do I want to
do that and so when you kind of have
that visceral response it's amazing how
much change can occur and so I think
you're at a beautiful spot in your story
Tierra like you are in a point where you
could say from this day forward I'm
doing something different with my money
and honestly for you I would say man I
would pick up an extra job I would cut
as much of your expenses as possible I
would work like a maniac and I would
knock out this credit card I would knock
out the student loan and it may take you
you know 18 24 months up to three years
so there's going to be a season of
sacrifice in your future but oh it will
be it will be so worth it when I talk to
you in 2027 you're going to be at a
completely completely different spot
financially and you're finally going to
say wow I I'm free I'm free and and it
is it's an it's an amazing thing Tierra
this is why we want you to sell the car
this is going to give you a huge jump
start when you start looking at all of
the debt that you have and you can wipe
away 14 000 in one transaction that's
going to give you a ton of momentum and
all of a sudden you can begin to see the
top of the mountain you know you can get
there am I right
yeah I agree I know it doesn't sound fun
right but if you want to get through
this you've got to jump start the
process okay and you'll get a better car
down the line but working extra hard
doing everything you can I mean gazelle
intensity is what we talk about that is
you are running for your life your
future life and you are sprinting and
you can do this I promise you you can do
this absolutely and tiara I would even
take those three credit cards I know you
said that there were two smaller ones
and most of them on one
then write those out write out that you
have four debts that you're like okay
here's the two small credit cards from
smallest to largest and writing out all
your debt because knocking out you could
knock out maybe two of these credit
cards with that extra money you have
from selling the car and it's like
they're gone cut them up they're done
they are done and that's gonna feel so
good it's the small moments on these
wins that actually give you hope in the
situation that you can know I can do
this and let me tell you this show gives
us the opportunity every day to talk to
people and we've heard every number you
can imagine from debt level to income
everything and the one consistent
attribute that people have that stand on
the debt-free stage and scream out that
they are debt free that they have no
more payments is that they believe that
they can
and they said I'm going to take charge
and the decisions I have to make day to
day I'm going to make those decisions on
what's best for my future and not give
in to instant gratification and in the
moment what feels good but I have a big
why I have a big journey ahead of me and
they know that they can do it not that
that makes it easy it's going to be hard
it can be exhausting it's going to be
exhausting
but the belief of seeing it Knocking out
those smaller debts there's something
powerful about it so hold on the line
Sierra because Austin's gonna pick up
and I want to give you Financial Peace
University and every dollar for a year
every dollar is going to help you
budgets it's going to help you stay on
track it's going to show you where I can
cut stuff it's going to keep you in line
for your food your rent everything
utilities everything uh and it's going
to be a great tool and then go through
the nine week or the nine lessons in
Financial Peace University because
that's going to give you a strong
Foundation to understand some of this
even more and what to do next so thank
you so much for the call
I love hearing those moments though Ken
yeah and and that's like a perfect
example and I hope to hear you're still
listen because man we hear those calls
and people say I'm done I'm done that's
right and then they get to make a
decision of what I'm gonna do something
crazy I'm gonna sell my car I'm gonna
sell my car I'm glad you brought it up
because you can hear the weariness in
her voice you asked her why what what
was the impetus of the call and she goes
I'm tired you could hear she's tired
yeah but now she's got to go from tired
to ticked off
like that's the progression I'm weary
and then I'm going to get mad about this
wait a second I don't have to live this
way I don't want to live this way I'm
going to do something so Tierra hang in
there but get mad get mad get ticked off
at this debt make it personal you're
gonna knock it out before you know it
you'll look back one day and you'll say
it was worth every sacrifice it was
worth every extra job it was worth
driving around a piece of crap a whole
nine yards it's always worth it trust me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
comes from Philippians Brothers I do not
consider that I have made it my own but
one thing I do for getting the lies
behind what lies behind and straining
forward to what lies ahead I press
toward the goal for the prize of the
upward call of God in Jesus Christ
I am not interested in the past except
as the road to the Future Versace yeah
thank you Austin for pulling up Versace
quote did you give him the Versace nudge
like hey I'd like to have a Versace
quote every once in a while he's giving
me like um
Ralph Lauren or Lauren however you
choose to pronounce it Ken I know you
have opinions on that we had a
conversation he gives me you like
Versace have you seen versace's house in
Miami you ever been South Beach I've
been to South but you've been to his
house well yeah right there on the front
I didn't go inside and have a you know
beverage but I've been to the front door
it's right there on South Beach by the
way that's very fun yeah it's beautiful
as you might imagine I could only I can
only imagine you should as some would
say yeah
all right up next we have Sue in
Milwaukee hey Sue welcome to the show
hey Richland Ken thank you so much for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help okay okay so
um I'm basically a fairly new listener
and I'd like some guidance for help to
settle an argument that I'm having with
my husband uh-oh and what the argument
is
is do we pay off the house
or do we not pay off the house to keep
money around for this inflation and
recession that's our way all right now
before we get any further we got to know
whose argument is oh should we know yes
should we we absolutely got to know
because Sue's on the line so what is
your what is your argument what is your
husband's argument
okay so my thought is from listening to
you guys we should pay off the house
okay
okay and he feels that we shouldn't
because we don't know what's going to
happen with this inflation and uh
recession into the next year got it all
right so okay give us some numbers so
how much is left on the mortgage
okay so you'll be real surprised it's
just and I just got my statement today
so it's 16 80 or 16
897. okay and how much do you guys have
in savings
50 50 000. what is your income
um well mine right now is zero basically
I have a beamer business and I only make
about
I don't know let's say five grand a year
and he's been doing Uber and he makes
about 20.
okay
so y'all y'all don't have like full-time
job I mean so you're living on twenty
five thousand dollars a year Sue
yeah but you see the thing of it is is
um he's like semi-retired okay okay and
I lost my job
and I had gotten a um a buyout okay
and that's what we're living at so when
you see what I have left from the box
that is a fifty thousand dollars all you
guys have that you're and you're living
off that fifty thousand
we're living off the 50 000 but no it is
not all that we have okay what all what
what other what other um savings or
retirement do you guys have
um 1.3 oh amazing Sue okay so you're
okay Megan wow this I'm I'm stunned you
have 1.3 million in retirement
yes and when you said your husband was
semi-retired what does that mean does
that mean he's drawing some some
retirement oh okay okay so what it means
is he retired like three years ago I
think it is now okay and to just kind of
keep busy and doing something he does
Uber okay no no I get I get that but is
he drawing some retirement or pension or
something from his work no pension just
Social Security okay so he is so he's
got Social Security so you're living off
of the Social Security as well correct
correct okay how old are you guys
he's 67 and I'm 64. and the thing of it
is is that I I've been we've been using
that money okay
to supplement of course our income
because I don't want to start drawing on
my Social Security until I'm full
retirement age which won't be until I'm
66 and 8 months okay all right you guys
need to pay the house off you got 1.3
million and you haven't even started
touching your Social Security and he's
at least not for me but I know we are
drawing on him yeah but but you called
and you wanted to settle the argument I
wish your husband was on the line if
he's in the other room tell him to get
on the phone because he's he's out
ubering yeah well listen you guys need
to pay the house off
you got 50 in the bank you still have 34
left after you pay the house off
right so you don't think it would be
because his whole thing is if we dwiddle
that down is that going to be enough to
last us till I reach full retirement age
so that
um if I start drawing now like from our
pensions or from our you know our
retirement fund then we have to pay
taxes yes it's enough money yes it's
enough but let's just get real on the
numbers okay here we go what is his
Social Security payment what's he
drawing out of Social Security every
month how much
just two grand two grand what are your
household expenses
including your mortgage which is really
low what are your household expenses our
mortgage payment is only 397 a month
right but what is your household
expenses everything included groceries
utilities everything gas everything
I don't know I
I would probably about two thousand okay
that's just on his Social Security all
right so he's also driving Uber and
right and you could work you could work
another year so you could go do
something
opportunities for you
well that's why you know it's like I'm
doing my Beamer business but no that's
hard no no no no no no you are you don't
need to be doing anything hard right now
if you want to do that as a hobby great
and it makes a little extra money
fantastic but you two are still healthy
enough to be working and he's already
driving Uber so he's making money above
and beyond so we're going to give you
guys Financial Peace University and I
want you guys to get on a budget all
those things but here's the point you
guys are going to make life even easier
even more inflation proof by paying off
the house you don't have a mortgage you
guys have no payments that's 300 a month
back in your account and when you
there's no risk right if the whole world
goes up you guys got 1.3 a paid for
house you got nothing you guys are
incredible shape you and Well Done sue
you guys have worked hard I could just
tell him we're just going to pay it off
this month yes because the interest
rates keeps going up yes yes the
treasury whatever you guys have over a
million dollars y'all are great sue you
are inflation proof
you think so I know so yes okay because
he's just he's totally against tell him
to turn off the TV yeah turn off the
news time to watch this on YouTube and
and because seriously I mean you guys
have another year right and then you
guys can start drawing from this from
retirement living your retirement dreams
you guys got this it'll probably be like
two years okay but listen listen when
you pay off the house today all right or
tomorrow you have 300 now back in your
account to take care of inflation that's
what he wants to know I would speak to
him that way I pay off the house we have
no worries at all
and the extra 300 a month takes care of
any inflation you guys live very
frugally anyway don't you so your
everyday millionaires you're doing it
you're doing incredible you're everyday
millionaires it's fantastic
baby stop smelling babies right there
right there Sue right there man
when she said 1.3 I don't fell out of my
chair I was thinking 50 000 that's all
you got in 16 maybe I would hold off a
little bit and you know bulk up that
emergency you know I was you know
thinking through like expenses if you're
only making 25 000 a year and you know
all this and then she throws out the 1.3
number what do you got in retirement uh
1.3 this real nonchalant 1.3
man this is fantastic so great oh how
about this hard work over over a long
time Sue poor guys out there driving
Uber right now really proud of you guys
should have patched into the car and got
him told him hey pal look you're in
great shape doing great go play some
shuffleboard tomorrow
go enjoy your life Ken great show
everyone in the booth Austin will oh
just all those exact answer everything
thank you America for listening it's
always a pleasure to be part of your
life so thanks so much for calling
chatting with us hope you have a great
weekend this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]